okay so Arthur Aquaman gets his badass
news from his mama in the film from you
so I wonder what's a badass movie you
got from your mama in reality I think my
brain I got I got a brain that some able
to it's just I hopefully it's a smart
brain she's waste matter than me but she
gave me some of that yeah but the movie
is a great movie about female
empowerment - are you bringing your
girls to see it or have they already
seen it they're here my girls have been
taken in the side wait keeps with them
so they're sitting in there eating
popcorn waiting for me to come in and I
have all the kids from big little lies
here tonight not all of them but most of
them the ones that could come so I just
had dad's the voice that play my twins
Nikki and Cameron in here with them yeah
they're in their blue suits so they're
like my other children so yeah family
affair yeah yeah they were all so
excited to see the movie which is a
great thing you know for kids to be able
to go and see this it's the holidays you
do you kind of have like a superhero
fantasy that you're living out with this
movie I wanted to have a kick-ass action
sequence that's what I really wanted and
I also wanted to work with James I'm a
huge fan of his and obviously his work
in horror but to see him come and do
this and foster the Furies he just did
that and now he's doing this I just love
that he's he's just so willing to take
on the big ones you know I just saw the
picture of us gretchen carlson today
right what is it like being a part of a
cast with so many like powerful
fantastic women to bring the story to
life it's it's Jay Roach is directing it
and Charlize is Megan Kelly and in my
garage and Alison Janey and Connie
Britton who's one of my best friends and
so it's a bunch of women getting
together to hopefully make a really good
film and a wedge Gretchen tweeted out
not the most supportive tweet today did
you see it I didn't I never see tweet
you don't ever know
I didn't do my work and is having her
support though important to you well I'm
really in the hands of the director
right now so hopefully I'll be good you
know and if I'm not I'm not I'll do my
best
there's no hopefully you're gonna be
good thank you can you try
[Music]